this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by movement movement
watches was founded on the belief that
style shouldn't break the bank the
watchmakers goal is to change the way
consumers think about fashion by
offering high-quality minimalist
products at revolutionary prices we'll
talk about this later on in the show but
get 15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to MVM t.com slash
Congrats this episode is all to you
Brook also brought to you by the cash
app I don't know if you've seen this but
the cash app has done something amazing
they've introduced the cash card it's a
new black debit card that you can design
yourself via the app and it allows you
the cash cart allows you to use the cash
that you keep in the app anywhere you
want and now that you have the cash app
which is the best way to pay people back
plus the all new cash card it's really
awesome
I'll talk about this more later on in
the show as well download the free cash
app for iOS or Android now hi my babies
it's it's episode 35 what's up babies
it's Chris and it's on dude episode 35
we keep getting higher right Kenny get
[Music]
so tone-deaf so yeah I this past weekend
I did two shows in Texas Christian
University and then I went to Penn State
and every time I say Penn State I every
time I think I say Penn State or think
of Penn State there's a rap song where
the guy says yeah I thought girls at
Penn State and I don't know what song it
is
but like it always made me laugh and I
heard it once and now I keep I show you
just Google yeah I [ __ ] girls at Penn
State but the rapper's like yeah I [ __ ]
girls at Penn State and it's like such a
weird brag like a specific only in
[ __ ] Pennsylvania uh yeah there's a
cut like like that's what imagine that
was your brag like you're hanging out or
like that was indignant that was the
thing that was in like didn't like
question was like yeah that's the thing
about him is he doesn't [ __ ] girls at
Penn State and they're like oh is it
notorious b.i.g [ __ ] the state pen [ __ ]
hoes at Penn State or maybe that's what
it is
or maybe they said something and he just
says [ __ ] [ __ ] them all right well
completely have no idea what it is
actually I liked it better what I
thought it was but it's all about the
Benjamins it's in there okay cool all
right well we figured it out and it's
wrong so anyway anyway babies hey look
sometimes our fearless leader is gonna
be wrong um I like how some people why
is it people just started calling
because it's a cult they call it the
fearless leader who's the [ __ ] said I
was fearless I actually did a whole bit
on this podcast about how everyone has
fear leader with fear that's some real
[ __ ] that's some real real real [ __ ] one
time I was one time I was listening to
the radio on the way to school and mace
was on this on the [ __ ] radio and
they were doing an interview and mace it
was this rapper that I guess a lot of
the kids probably don't know but he was
on all about was he done all about the
Benjamins I don't know but he was like
this P Diddy protege that stopped
rapping and became a pastor and nothing
is more obvious than a rapper quitting
and then becoming a pastor
and so yeah but he's not on all about
the Benjamins but he he was doing an
interview and he was like he was like
doing a quiz they were doing some on the
radio and they were like if you get this
right and he was like if they get this
right what did he get mace what are you
gonna give him and he was like I'm gonna
give him something real special and they
were like oh okay cool well what that's
awesome so if they get this right you
know you calling get this right what
Mesa can give him something real special
and you say yeah if they get it right
i'ma give him something real real real
real real real special and every time he
said it he added a few more reals until
it became like I'm again something well
well well well well really real real
real special and my brother and I left
so hard it's weird that these rappers
are 40 dude like he's 40 and that it
seems like he should be 67 like I'm 37
these guys were three years older than
me and when I was in high school they
were [ __ ] making dope songs and [ __ ]
now give me the catalogue I'll show you
had that the boss
that's a lyric from Ace now given the
catalogue I said I had that e boss like
giving you having his kid be like hey
why don't you get the joseline main
catalog there I want to show you what I
could buy if I want to and then here you
go and and then bass is like okay so
this the catalog I could buy this
dresser talk about that bad
I could buy a few these beds like about
these end tables I could buy this
chandelier I could get this over here I
could get this rug I could get a few of
these rugs I could get them in every
color anyway go to bed worst dad ever
now give me the catalog I say you had
that the boss ha ha ha the kid will grow
up to be a [ __ ] monster
are you [ __ ] kidding me my dad balls
when I would [ __ ] be a kid he would
give me the catalogue and he would show
me how much he bawled you show me what
he could get did he get it no but you
know you could have so I do too all
these rappers rap these every song look
at the look at this song that he would
do though I go down this is a P Diddy no
it was just there
any of these actually alright there we
go though I'm never drug free when I'm
in the club G I get him this is always
think about the police you just know I
could it be could it be I move as smooth
as Bugsy get him rock my ice pull out
blocks get him uh yeah really you know
get him it's so many so many uh cement
so much illegal activity get him yeah
shut that [ __ ] in the face
get him I'll murder everything moving
get him get a minority report style
because he didn't do it yet so dude what
if P did he starred in Minority Report
instead of Tom Cruise it'll be my
favorite song may remove a movie of all
time alright so uh so is that TCU as
that Penn State
TCU to colleges let me tell you some of
our college gigs okay so there the
harder good they're good they have a
good time but they don't laugh the
hardest because I have a theory that
when you do a coke a when you do with a
college the kids are kids and they're
still they're still like trying to
figure out who they are and they don't
want to be the people that stick out the
most so what happens is they they don't
wanna be the person that laughs the
hardest because they're and then they're
the biggest quote-unquote dork okay so
they all laugh like this that's it
that's every laugh and so you're
sweating your [ __ ] ass up there and
then you're like is this even good and
then afterwards you get tweets and
they're like oh that was [ __ ] great
this is great that's great and you're
like alright well then [ __ ] laugh
harder college kids I mean come on dude
and so I'm sitting there like [ __ ]
sweating so hard I wore a [ __ ] maroon
shirt therefore saw all the wet marks in
the middle of my chest and under my
armpits so if you're a comedian don't
wear a grey shirt on when you're doing
colleges cuz you can the sweat so hard
and it's always set up it's always a
makeshift [ __ ] place like it's in a
some [ __ ] conference room that they
never use and you have to be like could
you guys turn
the lights because it looks like they're
getting abducted because it's so bright
and then I did Penn State the TCU one
was [ __ ] bonkers was awesome the Penn
State one was okay and it's in the
middle of the [ __ ] in nowhere dude
these college towns are crazy they have
the most beautiful college town the most
beautiful [ __ ] buildings man these
colleges it just looks like whenever I
Drive to colleges it just I oh I went to
NYU for one year so I don't really have
that college experience so the only
thing I know about colleges is movies
and every movie about college is either
like this this like fun typists movie
where oh god one of the characters is
gonna get a finger up his butt when he
gets too high and the other guy is gonna
[ __ ] streak down the corridor naked
and then get in trouble with the Dean
you know and and they're gonna have like
sweeping [ __ ] wide shots of the
college in the beginning like but you
know and then the [ __ ] alright well
it's tough to see my kid all grown up
but oh god
and she's like man you know how your
father gets and then he's like mom yeah
we get it
whoa Joe Oh football almost hit her in
the head
hey what's up see you later and then
that becomes a guy that she sees later
on in the [ __ ] the end of the first
act that's like oh he's he's the jerk
that did that or it's like a [ __ ]
serious college movie there's either
that college movie or the serious
college movie we're [ __ ] somebody
like the school ties thing or where
somebody ends up hanging themselves or
like somebody gets like raped I hate to
say it but like yeah so that's all I
know about college is really so I I did
those colleges and it was fun and then I
came back and think but college shows
were kind of tame in that way not like
the New Jersey show which I forgot to
tell you guys about this but when I was
in the clubs when the club shows can be
can get crazy so this one girl did I
talk about this on the stun where the
girl [ __ ] was yelling out your sexy
no all right so this girl was like
you're sexy I have a crush on you
interrupting the show some humblebrag
don't mean to but that's what she was
yelling she was like you're sexy I've
had a crush on you have no idea for how
long and I was like alright that's cool
but mmm
just tweet me about it and then I looked
to the right and then I looked to the
left and she was on stage on stage
faster than faster Dan [ __ ] so quick and
she was so tall and she was so drunk she
was so drunk she looked like it was
animatronics you know what I mean like
she was like trying to [ __ ] like
there was somebody behind her trying to
[ __ ] be like we've almost got all the
kinks worked out and she was just like
and then she was had a beer of course
and then she had white and black striped
dress on and I said why you dressed like
the Hamburglar and then she laughed and
then she got kicked out she got kicked
out and I said who's with her and some
lady was like me and I was like you
didn't leave and she was like nah and I
was like are you staying for the show
she said yeah I said what are you in
relation to the little girl and she said
I'm her mom the mom stayed cuz the
daughter got too drunk and rushed the
stage and told the [ __ ] comedian that
she had a crush on him and she's sexy
hey you got probs in your family Hey
don't mean to be disrespectful you
raised her too quick you let her get
away with too much [ __ ] when she was 7
that's why she's on stage with me I mean
come on dude so and then of course the
club owners were like I'm so sorry Mike
it's not you man everyone's got a mind
of their own do it everyone's got a mind
of their own if someone's gonna rush the
stage they're gonna rush the stage do it
it's just going to happen so yeah
that's crazy though that that happened
actually I can't believe that people do
[ __ ] like that
I guess drunk I've never been drunk
straight up ever I've never been drunk I
know that's it's so weird and every time
I tell somebody that I've never been
drunk can't stand that they say like
that's really cool man I actually really
respect that I'm not doing it for that
reason I literally don't even know why
I'm doing it in the beginning I didn't
drink because I it was too typical like
everyone in high school was doing it and
they're like this what you're supposed
to do and I was like nope I can't do
that God be my own person that's why I'm
the leader if I'm the leader with fear
of the cult I'm no [ __ ] beta dude I'm
not gonna drink cuz you say so
no take that [ __ ] beer and go to
Coachella why don't you take that beer
go to Burning Man why don't you take
that beer go to Burning Man why dontcha
babe so yeah I can't yeah so then when I
got to college I was like well I'm
definitely not gonna start drinking at
college cuz that's so predictable
so then after college I was like it's
[ __ ] kind of too late what am I gonna
start doing it when I'm 22 no I don't
want to call it free year anyway but the
college dropouts gonna start drinking
it's a typical right so then I was like
okay I'm not gonna I'm not gonna do it
then I just never did it and then I
never was cared about it and I don't
give a [ __ ] I never drank not true and
and and I don't and and here's the worst
part too every time someone says so so
what's up you're not drinking tonight
and I say nines did you drink I say no
and they say oh and then I say they say
do you've never drank and I say listen I
say no I never drank and then they and
then they always say like never and then
I say yeah never and then they say and
then they always say oh you even that
you've never had a sip you've never like
drank at all no so you've never drunk no
what about like like even like wow
that's how the conversation always goes
and I always have to be so nowadays how
I answer the question hey you're not
drinking tonight no and I want you to
know something
I don't drink and I want you to know
something further than that I've never
drank and no matter how many times in
different ways you ask me that question
the answer is going to be the same I've
never drank and then they go like this
well well Wow
they they can't help themselves you got
a [ __ ] you know adapt to the world
dude you gotta adapt to the [ __ ]
world and if people are gonna be doing
that you never drink no don't drink no
how many times gonna ask this question I
say how many times you gonna [ __ ] ask
this question then I see them get [ __ ]
nervous smile cuz they realized what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] went down somebody asked me
the other day would you take a bullet
for me and I was like uh it depends I
was like here's the deal if it was a
quick knee-jerk reaction then I think
probably I would try and jump in the way
but if somebody was like I'm gonna shoot
your [ __ ] person or friend are you
gonna take it instead it'd be a lot
harder of a decision if I had to have
[ __ ] time to think about the [ __ ] I'd
probably be like just shoot him but like
you know I'll try to rush him to the
hospital afterwards you know like but if
someone was like you know about to shoot
my mom BAM I'd be like mom no and I'd
move out the way but if some [ __ ]
like German dude came up and was like
I'm about to shoot your Massa how would
you like to deal with this I'd be like
I'm gonna fight you dude
you know but like I don't know if I
would jump in front of the [ __ ]
bullet in if I had time to think about
it which means I'm a hero but not if you
give me the option do you know what I
mean not if you give me the [ __ ]
option for longer than four seconds mmm
hero make no mistake hero but it's got
to happen really quickly dude you know
I'm saying and even with the really
quickly [ __ ] I'm not sure I might be
like oh [ __ ] who's too fast so sorry
let's go to the hospital you know I
think that's how everybody would be cuz
really what a hero is
it's kind of a dumb [ __ ] if you think
about it they're putting everything out
there throwing everything out the window
all caution and all everything and
they're just like no I'm just gonna do
it
I'll jump I'll jump and try to save the
person when it's like oh you put both of
your [ __ ] lives at risk you [ __ ]
dummy now I'm not saying well we need
more heroes in this world and I [ __ ]
applaud anybody that risks their life to
save anybody but it's like a hero or
maybe you just kind of a little bit
stupider than the rest of us you're not
I'm saying I'm not talking about guys in
the army I get that that's some
well-thought-out [ __ ] you want a [ __ ]
ride for our country I get it but people
who are like if you jumped off this
building
I'd jump off and try to break your fall
you kind of just stupid yeah hero really
simple hey you hear oh we got a
birdbrain dude um yeah I don't know I
don't know I'm not I'm not I'm I don't
know you know like I don't know is a
hero in there you know there's a hero in
there okay
so I don't know if I take a bullet for
somebody but dude I've been on the road
so much every time I go on the road I
watch the [ __ ] what do you call it
the what's that [ __ ] succinylcholine
oh by the way they came up with a
hundred new like so many new episodes of
[ __ ] what's it called Forensic Files
and they [ __ ] didn't they they the
guy died the voice his name is the voice
and he died so I don't know who's gonna
do it but I'm they're gonna [ __ ] it up I
know they are I know they're gonna [ __ ]
it up I used to watch the show extreme
engineering and it was so dope it would
be like the largest building in [ __ ]
Japan Japanese people build some crazy
[ __ ] it'll go up to heaven it'll go up
to heaven they'll make a building
that'll go up to heaven and they'll be
like and it'll sway with the wind and
they'll be like it can't be [ __ ] too
stiff because it we're gonna to be o2
stiffer it has to swing with the wind so
everybody in the building is like
[ __ ] shuckin and jivin with the wind
but and the extreme engineering was the
[ __ ] I bought it on iTunes I pay
for the [ __ ] season it was like 40
bucks and then they changed it it was
some like [ __ ] guy that was now the
host of it dude I do understand if
there's a host of his show get the [ __ ]
out of here
make the guy just do vo and show
beautiful images now I gotta watch some
guy with glasses and a hard hat walking
around some [ __ ] oil rig get out of
here I got to watch some [ __ ] guy
that would look like he'd be in a
Verizon commercial tromping around on a
[ __ ] in a skyscraper so when they
first made this they decided to go with
[ __ ] balsa wood so the whole building
wouldn't collapse if the wind blew it
now it just sways get out of here
[ __ ] buck up get a guy with
low-hanging balls and [ __ ] just talk
over some beautiful images it's not
steel because steel would [ __ ] book
look [ __ ] book
I can't stand it dude when a guy [ __ ]
when they change what they're doing
don't [ __ ] fix what ain't broke dude
extreme engineering was the illest [ __ ]
dude
they had stuff through their stuff in
the world that was built that you have
no [ __ ] idea that it was built I
swear to God like in Australia who's the
guy by the way it's it's I don't give a
[ __ ] dude why does everybody in a come
everybody in every commercial looks
goddamn the same why it's either a
[ __ ] white guy with a shaved face and
[ __ ] wire-rimmed glasses and a
[ __ ] button-down blue shirt by or
it's a [ __ ] chubby chubby or white
guy with a [ __ ] little bit of stubble
or a beard and [ __ ] orange hair by or
it's a black guy who looks like really
nice and presentable like the black guy
that even [ __ ] racist parents would
would be like oh yeah okay cool he's a
nice he he'd be like oh he's a nice one
yeah [ __ ] that bye okay or they'd be or
like there's that leather the funky
black guy or there's the girl with like
beige-ish hair by well all I did was
well I sign up for Verizon and Mama for
Mom some huh
I have sex with my boyfriend once every
three weeks
by that's what the girl looks like or
there's like an ambiguous like is she
Asian or [ __ ] or a Mexican girl hi
there's never a cool dude on commercial
unless it's a car commercial I [ __ ]
hate how serious car commercials are
you're selling a car not life insurance
you're selling a car not grave plots
you're selling a car not the first robot
you're not you're not a [ __ ] all the
camera I just any commercial that's like
remember the first Google commercial I
cryed cryed we've been with you since
any commercial every any commercial that
has that we've been with you since gonna
cry we remember cry we remember when you
were there for we were there for you
when you cry when your daughter first
cry see ya Hawk the product [ __ ] boy
don't have the illest guy in the car
driving along the streets are always wet
even though it's [ __ ] you know what I
mean in a place that never rains oh
you're in downtown LA how about the fact
that it never rains and some guy who
looks like he's a Banana Republic model
is sitting in a [ __ ] Lincoln no guy
would drive that car that guy wouldn't
drive that car and you know it and he's
got a little bit of stubble and he's
smiling a little bit over at the [ __ ]
lady and they're always married they're
always married they never have anybody
in a commercial that's not married it's
always a married guy cuz you can trust
him hey what is this the 40's we get it
now and he's driving and he's [ __ ] we
were there with you when this happened
and we'll be there with you when that
happens
Lexus that's the [ __ ] thing
we were there for you when you first Sam
anima chunga doesn't matter we'll be
there for you when you die Lexx us
I mean the guy who does the extreme
engineers [ __ ] [ __ ] his name is Danny
Forrester fake name that's like a name
if you were honestly meeting each a
sidechick and they were like well what's
your name and you'd be like Danny
you'd be like didn't it and she'd be
like really what's your last name and
you'd be like you'd go to say foster but
then you wouldn't because you'd be like
that's too typical so you'd be like
Forester Forester Forester yeah it's got
an R in it
yeah Forester are you [ __ ] kidding me
you're cheating on your girlfriend Danny
Forrester is the most cheatin ass
[ __ ] [ __ ] ever look at this guy hey
Danny Forrester could you look more like
you made an app damn dude
oh there's a [ __ ] Google image where
he's wearing a scarf of course hey dude
don't give a [ __ ] who you are never wear
a scarf I don't give a [ __ ] who you are
I don't care if you're in the tundra
what's the tundra by the way is it cold
or hot don't wear a scarf in the tundra
don't wear a scarf get a [ __ ] high
jacket how about that get a jacket with
a collar you are a scarf in the tundra
[ __ ] out of my face you wear a scarf you
wear a scarf in New York [ __ ] out of my
face you were a scarf in LA [ __ ] why
is your nose facing my nose turn round
the pants lower them if you were a scarf
in the [ __ ] in LA ever good dunk you
CUDA you kudiye kudiye dunk turn round
come on dude
how about that [ __ ] idiotic picture
with what's that guy's name who's the
balls [ __ ] fell out of his pants when
he was rockin Lenny Kravitz Lenny
Kravitz do it how about Lenny Kravitz in
that idiotic scarf he wears in that
picture hey it's too big bye
hey man you could wrap up your whole
goddamn family in it bye what are you in
the [ __ ] he looks like he's in the
comfy matrix
he looks like the [ __ ] he looks like
he's in the [ __ ] comfy matrix what
would you like the little scarf or the
big scarf how comfortable do you want to
be lenny kravitz would you like a scarf
dude and then there's that photoshop
picture where they made it [ __ ] way
bigger [ __ ] him dude straight up hey
lenny kravitz your scarves to bake pie
in the comfy matrix would you like the
red pill or the blue pill the red pill
gives you a regular-sized scarf you'll
be nice and warm you'll be warm in LA
and probably even in New York but in the
tundra you'll freeze or you can take the
blue pill the blue pill gives you a
larger scarf and even in the tundra
you'll be very warm and lenny Kravitz's
i I'll take the blue pill
we don't wear whale here you go and then
he did it and then [ __ ] rocked out
spread his legs to wide with his skinny
jeans and his balls fell out hey lenny
kravitz your boss fell out while you
were rocking out you know welcome to mm
whatever it was you know never happen
Elvis and he [ __ ] did lots of open
leg [ __ ] it happened to me once once I
was on stage at the Jon Lovitz comedy
club it was a makeshift comedy club that
was in San Diego for a little bit and of
course it went out of business but hey
Jon level Jon Lovitz comedy club in San
Diego course it's going out of business
anyway had some [ __ ] speakers up on
tripod see ya so that he's a nice guy
but dude right and so so I [ __ ] did
the [ __ ] I did a splits on stage what
not a splits I [ __ ] did a [ __ ]
dance like I do and my [ __ ] pants
straight up opened up and thank God I
had [ __ ] underwear on because my
balls would a little Rafael into the
first and second row with the audience
because they're so goddamn big dude my
balls are so big dude it's crazy man
they would I would've literally killed
or whatever they would have died the
people in the front row would have died
cuz my balls would have suffocated them
but what's the song that he does the
[ __ ] just wanna [ __ ] get away just
saw on a flower yeah
yeah gonna [ __ ] fly away with it what
dude you know what huh what
[Music]
he literally water wrote that song woke
up in the morning was just like he hung
him write a [ __ ] song today you
[ __ ] [ __ ] he said that to whoever
was next to him to the chick some
[ __ ] superhot model and he had a
scarf on when he woke up and he was like
hey I'm Lenny Kravitz dude get out of my
house
yo I'm gonna write a [ __ ] song today
[ __ ] and she [ __ ] left and he was
just like wrote the song with only a
shirt on and a big-ass scarf and the
whole time he was thinking about like I
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that's what he was
thinking you know dude Lenny Kravitz is
a is a real person how about when Lenny
Kravitz did the target commercial and
everybody was like he sold out oh shut
the [ __ ] up dude let me tell you
something man if I had 75 number-one hit
singles you better goddamn believe I'm
doing commercials for Target Starbucks
McDonald's Apple [ __ ] Banana Republic
Lexus all the companies dude all the
companies and I'm raking in I'm raking
in the [ __ ] money I'm [ __ ] raking
in the money Kohl's commercial Lenny
Kravitz did it Kohl's commercial what do
they sell pots and pans to [ __ ] this
cold sell everything right you can get
anything at Kohl's you can literally buy
an elf from Kohl's you can go into calls
me like we're your elves and they'd be
like Aisle seven hey what's up hey how's
that Darwin did you need one how tall
are you I'm three feet you have anyone
smaller
yeah just go down go further down that
red and then then do way down that way
they're like how tall are you
I'm sorry okay I'll take two of you cool
let's go Tim okay Travis and then you're
gonna boop boop got two trolls or what
let me say else got two elves cool and
I'll get some towels too and some pots
and pans chopping up combs come on get
in the car you [ __ ] elves what the
[ __ ] am I talking about this is the most
derailed episode the comfy matrix though
it's that's where Lenny Kravitz lives
[Music]
movement movement watches was founded on
the belief that style shouldn't break
the bank the watchmakers goal is to
change the way consumers think about
fashion by offering a high-quality
minimalist product at revolutionary
prices it's great 1 million watches sold
to customers in 160 plus countries in
the world I didn't know there were that
many countries mediate I have one of
these watches it's very cool it's gold
and it makes me look like a boss player
you know what I mean like people look at
me and they're like okay that kind of
what's going on because I have this
watch they started just 95 dollars at a
department store you're looking at 400
to 500 bucks
say yeah you don't wanna break the bank
get on movement movement figured out by
selling online that they were able to
cut the middleman out and cut the the
retail markup and providing the best
possible price get 15% off today with
free shipping and free returns by going
to MVM t.com slash Congrats
I've been getting compliments ever since
I put mine on it's actually every time I
wore it I think I got a compliment on it
so now is the time to step up your watch
game go to MVM t.com slash Congrats join
the movement lift they know what their
drivers they know that their drivers are
what keep them moving
literally and also emotionally and also
theoretically so they do everything they
could they do to make sure their drivers
are happy on every trip it's a simple
formula happy drivers make happy
passengers that's how it goes it's the
trickle-down theory okay maybe that
by nine out of ten lift rides get a
perfect five-star rating lift was the
first ride share platform with tipping
built right into the app okay everyone
else copied the Kudus so you want to
earn more money drive more but drivers
have been paid over two hundred million
dollars since the feature was first
introduced that's a lot of money okay
Express pay lets you get paid almost
instantly instead of waiting for weeks
so join the ride-sharing company that
believes in treating its people better
go to lift calm slash Congrats today and
you can get five hundred dollar new
driver bonus that's lift calm / Congrats
lift calm / Congrats now a limited time
only terms apply but you got to do this
lift is is the best and they treat their
drivers the best I'm gonna do this one
to quip and I'm gonna do it because I
like this company alright
here's something to chew on guys many
recent studies suggest that having a
good oral health impacts your overall
health yet most of us don't brush your
teeth properly now what's the deal with
that you'll want to start brushing
better today
so you're healthier today I got this
stuff they sent it to me and it's really
cool it's a company that's refreshing
the way people brush your teeth clip is
an electric toothbrush that packs
premium vibration and timer features
into an ultra slim design is very cool
it makes me feel like I'm in the Jetsons
it's half the cost of bulkier brushes
you can even subscribe to receive new
brush heads on a dentist recommended
three month plan for just five dollars
including free shipping qyp is backed by
the leading dentists and was named one
of Time Magazine's best inventions of
2016 ok they won a 2016 GQ grooming
award and made it on oprah's 2017 New
Year's Oh lists quip starts at just $25
right now go to get quip calm / congrats
to get your first refill pack with free
I get up free with equip electric
toothbrush that's get quip calm /
Congrats GE t qu IP comm / Congrats so
yeah Lenny Kravitz lives in the country
matrix I mean dude I should we should
play this here we got we got a song that
these guys made their call
what the band's called locals-only I
said right and yeah yeah the wool yeah
that's the locals only but they made a
band they made a side band called the
true babies and they made this song for
us and I say us cuz we're a cult it's
not just me it was for me but it's for
us and I tweeted it and this song is
called true babies called in it's called
the the band is called is from the true
babies inspired by locals only but this
song is called take them out and they
have obviously listened they told me
that they listened to every episode on
tour when they were on tour and this is
definitely this [ __ ] thing made me
how they've listened to every episode
obviously and this song is so funny and
it's actually really kind of it's good
the way they did it so let's hear it
true babies by locals only take them out
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] up my vag gotta get my money bags
back it right up to my pad in the Brinks
truck spotted Okura
told him to freeze Punk nobody watching
your Facebook live cuz freak on you
don't wanna see that breathe air a blood
red man like a mother from gonna be a
held after this
[Music]
howling when I heard that what they did
when they auto-tune my [ __ ] stupid
voice it's [ __ ] so funny man listen to
it while you [ __ ] you know what I was
thinking you know what I realized some I
don't we were talking about this with my
buddies they were saying that they like
to put on [ __ ] music while they're
having sex and I think that that's I
don't think that that's I think that you
shouldn't listen to me I think if you
listen to music while you [ __ ] that's
some real full-blown CUDA [ __ ] for real
because dude it takes away from the
sexiness of it number one and I know
people will be like what it makes it
more sexy but it doesn't dude first of
all if you're having sex with a girl you
kinda like and you put on some [ __ ]
lovely music you might fall in love
that's fake that's fake that's fake
b ridge it's free conch you can put on
whatever you want but that's fake
alright another thing is if you're
trying to impress a girl and your [ __ ]
having sex with her and you put on some
NWA and you might [ __ ] and try and blow
her back out
that's not cool either because that's
not how you are if you're not listening
to any music when you're making love or
doing it that's the [ __ ] because then
you get to hear all the noises feel what
it's really like and [ __ ] experience
the [ __ ] dude I'm gonna have sex and
listen to another guy singing huh oh
yeah let's have sex but also let's
involve other people no I want to hear
the [ __ ] I want to I want to focus on
the the kissing and the touching and the
thinking and the you know come on
[ __ ] while listening to Josh Groban
or Coldplay Sega imagine I mean you know
I don't do that I don't do that I don't
listen that dude I had a girlfriend once
and she was like why don't we never
listen to music when you have sex
because that's a full-blown Kudus [ __ ]
man I want to hear you no I don't want
to hear you know what the sexiest thing
to hear when you're having sex is the
daytime nothing sexier than if you're
having sex and you hear like in the
distance a lawnmower that's so hot bro
I'll immediately have an orgasm if I
hear a lawnmower when I'm having sex
that's it way in the background that's
it that's the really [ __ ] and then some
chicks or a bird just like in the back
you know this is so real I'm a real
person hurt oh god this is real life
Hart bird know like out what the [ __ ]
you want to hear the [ __ ] Dana nano
no nonononono nonononono no man
nano name a no-name a no-name nee-naw
nee-naw nee-naw nee-naw nee-naw no nano
[ __ ] out of here so much cake so many
piano notes while you're thrusting
massive a yellow that's no [ __ ]
Berber [ __ ] I'm talking about lawnmower
[ __ ] you hear kids playing in a pool
[ __ ] three yards over forget it
ultimate explosion looking it somebody
in their eyes while you hear a [ __ ]
trash van what do you call them trash
garbage trucks looking someone in the
eyes why you hear your garbage being
[ __ ] robot armed up into the hell
[ __ ] and violent is it by the way when
you see those [ __ ] trash can't make
it smoother dude when it picks up the
thing and it's like good and it throws
up in the [ __ ] and your brain and
you're looking in a girl's eyes through
her soul dude I'll tell you what man and
you know what another thing is that when
you make love there's no laughing bro
there's no laughing I don't give a [ __ ]
if some silly stuff happens you use it
for the seriousness of it you use it for
the seriousness of it look at how
[ __ ] violent it is and they miss all
the time - they [ __ ] miss all the
time I mean we got to show that on the
[ __ ] video podcast so don't give a
[ __ ] that's the guys the last day on the
job you know how violent are they listen
I can't even fit oh there's so robotic
make it it's not ready yet it's not
ready yet
these [ __ ] garbage can got trash
truck Josh Widdicombe garbage trucks not
ready yet Oh
jerky is that [ __ ] thing look how big
it is look at it okay get it
it looks drunk why is this on youtube
you know garbage can't man destroys
trash bucket because it was overfilled
nothing's happening um the robot arms
look like they're coming actually
because they're so jerky
oh oh it's hilarious this [ __ ] guys
I'm watching a video where this oh he
[ __ ] it up dude what a dick that would
be me that would be me there's rules
dude if it's overfilled like that I over
fill my [ __ ] all the time I would ruin
it but but my point is nothing is sexier
than hearing the daytime when you're
making love night having sex at night is
not as cool having sex the sexiest time
to have sex 4:30 p.m. thought about it
I've thought about this a lot 4:30 the
sun's in the cool spot where it might be
peeking through the blinds but you're
inside someone and you can hear kids
playing in a pool forget it forget it
oh no you think a night time is with a
bunch of [ __ ] khuda candles lit and
the lights are out and you're listening
to [ __ ] you raise me up or like by
the way not knocking the music Coldplay
and [ __ ] just grabbing her awesome
but listening to some Jack Johnson with
no shoes on that [ __ ] guy
hey Jack Johnson put shoes on put socks
on put shoes on no why you dolt
oh and girls just love it he doesn't
wear shoes did you know that he didn't
he doesn't wear shoes oh really
cool see ya alright cool
oh oh oh he's poor guys [ __ ]
millions of dollars to put shoes on yeah
but do it music while making love is
some [ __ ] serious if we were in my
coat you don't do that you don't do that
you do not do that you do not do that
dude you're not coming to the [ __ ]
log cabin straight up if you put on some
[ __ ] [ __ ] David Gray while you're
making love you don't do it square cash
everyone is switching to the cash app
because it's the best way to pay people
back
friends family ghosts badgers anyone
sending and receiving money is totally
free and fast and most payments can be
deposited directly into your bank
account within seconds here's how it
works you download the square cash app
link your debit or credit card select an
amount to send and type in a friend's
phone number or email address to
complete a payment look at a
notification that they've just received
money that's it no gimmicks Square cash
is cool because it's not a social
network a lot of these other guys are
and they'll have their payments listed
in a feed which is which is CUDA so
let's talk about the new cash card
alright it's a new black debit card that
you can design yourself via the app be
artistic get this the cash card allows
you to use the cash that you keep in the
app anywhere you want you get the
notifications for all payments made with
the card directly via the cash shop you
can laser-etched your card to
personalize it and it will be delivered
directly to you for free the artist this
is for you your creative this is for you
the cash app team is constantly building
awesome new features like this so what
are you doing using the other guys get
the cash app today
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now so yeah but that's that's
that's a my bag these [ __ ] slouchy
orange chairs are really good for my
really good for my back why is this
feels like there's feedback here
I don't know maybe a little bit yeah I
think so sorry if there's feedback but
whatever alright so here we go we're not
I don't know if we're gonna do this
every week but we're gonna start off two
weeks strong we've got a new alder we've
got some we've got we're gonna announce
our second order we sent out that did we
send out the pin yet or no yeah
send out the pin and the and and the
certificate to a plumb bomb or whatever
the [ __ ] his name is change it and so
we've got a new we've got so we've got
our second elders and there are two
we're naming two today because they are
together all right and it is their names
are Steve and Malika Bush now why is
your name not Monica I don't know it's
Mollica which is weird okay
change it to Monica but your name is
Monica which sounds like something that
would be really little inside a body and
scientists would talk about but they
reason the reason why they're named
elders are because is because they
created the most [ __ ] up Instagram
post of the week jingle so
congratulations to Steve and Mollica
Bush I'm gonna call you steep from now
on ste PE because your girl's name is
Mallika so you'll be receiving a pin and
certificate and you guys are now elders
so thank you very much for your
influence on this show and all that so
now join the join the elder a plum bomb
change it and Steve regular which is
very cool and Monica Monica change it so
you guys are all elbers elders it's
interesting we've got to change it's in
the elders which which is which is cool
but thank you very much that being said
let's let's get right into it okay but
let me look first and see which one
we're gonna do here because I [ __ ]
added some this this week and now of
course can't get it on the phone because
I'm the producer fixed my internet but
it's not working one firearm
[Music]
okay guys welcome to the most [ __ ] up
Instagram post of the week all right
well so this one is a picture of the
goddamn sky and here's the thing it's a
picture of the sky and then you can
swipe right and it's another picture of
the almost the same [ __ ] shot of the
goddamn sky so pick one pick the better
one post it don't want to have to swipe
right cuz I'm not gonna [ __ ] the sky all
right that's the thing is this tender no
Instagram cool
don't make me [ __ ] swipe left to right
cuz I'm not gonna [ __ ] the sky okay
so already you're in dangerous uh-oh
territory here is the caption under it
I'm most the guys obviously in a plane
or falling okay
I'm most thankful for moments like these
semicolon now use the semicolon in an
instagram caption blood red man okay
you're writing a [ __ ] document that
you need to show your co-workers know
don't use semicolon you could do in a
caption for instagram only use commas or
periods or dashes I'm most thankful this
is what he's most thankful for oh it's a
check this is what she's oh that's weird
it's a check oh that's weird it's a
chick getting emotional about the sky
hey that's weird
someone with a [ __ ] is getting
emotional over a picture of the sky what
the [ __ ] that's odd
what's next pigs are gonna UNK what's
next cars go vroom hey what the [ __ ] is
next pens right I'm most thankful for
moments like these semicolon change it
when the last date with the last rays of
sunlight
pickle your cheeks alright do it here's
the deal man
you're not a poet okay
rays of sunlight don't tickle [ __ ] you
know why cuz they're rays of sunlight
not your uncle okay
dude how many times in any books or
poems or anything have rays of sunlight
tickled something so many so many now
because you read a goddamn book and
you're on an airplane you think you can
tell me that rays of sunlight tickle
your cheeks turn around step back a
little bit
good thunk cuz you CUDA and I'm not
sorry for that congratulations combo
come on man you poet no you just work at
like [ __ ] you know somewhere okay bye
gheh conk oh well he got this sentence
isn't even over I thought the sentence
is over it's not over this she's Robert
Frost in this [ __ ] did Robert Frost
Locke lop off his [ __ ] it's crass I'm
most thankful for blasphemy it's a
blasphemic crass fulness I'm most
thankful for comments like I mean
[ __ ] Jesus what am I losing my mind
I'm most thankful for moments like these
semicolon change it when the last rays
of sunlight tickle your cheeks to say
their goodbyes Oh for [ __ ] sake dude
Hey they go into the army nah they're
just
rays of sunlight tickle your cheeks to
say their goodbyes and the clouds form a
perfect blanket covering the desert
below and even though you can't a this
sentence is a run-on tickle your cheeks
to say their goodbyes and the clouds
form a perfect blanket covering the
desert below and even though you can't
yet see the stars they're there waiting
for the darkness to come out and play
the kids are there darkness and all the
wild things stop and revere the fading
beauty of the day oh dude that's one
sentence I've got I've got news for you
makes no sense
stupid ik aka not poetic and also
there's so much punctuation in it and at
the end there's no period okay cool also
this is the best there's one comment
under it and they write this is stunning
with a heart eyes emoji which is awesome
because it says nothing about her
[ __ ] poetry dude you're not Robert
Frost you work as a schoolteacher or
something don't talk about how Sun
lights tickle your cheeks dude come on
man that's the most [ __ ] up Instagram
post of the week what do these people
think they are you code
alright let's look at some of these fan
questions let's go to these [ __ ]
congratulations this is pot alright
what is LARPing Oh what does it make you
this is from Steve Butler
what is it Steve Butler Steve underscore
Butler 18 does it make you BRM blood red
mad to see adults LARPing at a public
park at night
Oh swordplay in a park oh my god how old
are they
adults a lot of people do it let me see
the picture live-action role-playing
dude we got to the point where we don't
need swords and shields and we can
shower now and also [ __ ] is more
gettable than ever
okay I mean these guys look they [ __ ]
run around and try to hit each other
with swords and [ __ ] it's so dorky wow
these guys hey guys [ __ ] someone oh this
is hilarious look at what this guy's
even holding there always are like nerf
[ __ ] oh my god and they take badass
pictures it's not Game of Thrones lame
of Thrones ladies okay oh that's weird
one of the people one of the [ __ ]
look at they look like they don't shower
ah that's weird
unbelievable a look inside the world of
LARP I like how they make it sound more
like you know grand than it is this
guy's at a gas station explaining why
well basically Oh what why does it say
maggot the squirming is that his name oh
come on dude hey no you know what your
name is Dave that's it well you know I
mean I originally got into LARP because
what happened was I realized I woke up
one day and I realized it had been seven
years since I had sex and I
basically a Funyuns and squirt and that
was pretty much my diet and ate fast
food a lot and so what happened was I
went to a museum when it was closed
I stole a [ __ ] curtain and I cut a
hole in it put it over my head and I put
a bunch of what do you call it foam over
a shower rod and then I just started
beating the [ __ ] out of my neighbor and
then I made a shield with a skull on it
and now I just realized I don't need
[ __ ] I'm just gonna start beating the
[ __ ] out of the people who are gonna
come to the park with me what am i doing
tessa Dever noah tavern owner oh [ __ ]
I'm allergic to LARPing I guess anyway
Wow
what do I think of that I don't know hey
dude if you're having fun have fun do it
you're not hurting anyone even though
you are cuz you're beating the [ __ ] out
of somebody with a shower rod with
[ __ ] foam over it this is this
something that Dominic's ever
Severino I feel like we've seen you
before at Dominic's every no how do you
feel about people who wear a beanie when
they are at the gym working out but also
they were wearing a singlet yeah III
don't understand if you that's that goes
to everything if you have shorts on but
also a jacket let's go what's going on
were you molested as a kid what's going
on you're confused is it hot or cold out
you got a beanie on and also a tank top
whatcha doin what are you doing is it
hot or cold make up your [ __ ] mind
imagine trusting somebody that was
wearing a [ __ ] tank top and also a
beanie how could you trust that person
didn't even know if it's [ __ ] hot or
cold out oh dude and they're gonna tell
me oh you got to go see the second
Avengers movie it's awesome oh I'm gonna
trust you you don't even know if it's
[ __ ] you know what your body
temperature is that's like the guy who
[ __ ] has a truck and then gets the
[ __ ] thing that covers the flatbed on
the truck get an SUV I'm gonna trust
what you say now you don't even know
what the [ __ ] are you need
also here's another one that goes with
it system gamer which is obviously at
change eat at change eat Chris D'Elia
Chris Lea what about the car why'd
motorcycles trying to split lanes in LA
traffic turnaround gaming this gaming
the system
congratula you know what dude when I see
a big-ass motorcycle with like that
really like they look like it looks like
a [ __ ] praying mantises head that
big-ass front and the big-ass [ __ ]
globe headlight and there and the
[ __ ] bulky ass wheel covers and there
and the music is playing really loud
dude I want you to understand I actually
audibly laugh out loud when I see those
guys drive by I laugh out loud and
you're [ __ ] embarrassing yourself and
you always got a beard get a car cover
yourself up it's too wide hey are you a
motorcycle or J Lo's ass the only time
you can sit on that motorcycle is if
you're JLo because your ass is white as
[ __ ] dude come on man you're gonna get a
motorcycle that wide you're gonna get a
motorcycle
I can walk a crop across it look at this
person
Alex Meehan at Alex Meehan Chris Lea
have you ever zipped your beans in your
jeans that saying drives me [ __ ] nuts
but I have actually not my jeans I had a
when I was a kid a young kid I had on
those what do you call those onesies and
I zipped my [ __ ] dick up and I
[ __ ] cried so hard my mom came in and
I thought is it my dick up and she
didn't [ __ ] she was like oh that's
okay and I was like you don't understand
man you don't [ __ ] understand you
don't have a dick in my head in my
little brain I was like you don't
understand you don't have a dick but I
you know I didn't say it did I remember
that [ __ ] how dumb you have to be to zip
up your [ __ ] dick in your jeans by
the way how dumb you have to be do you
have a onesie on and zip your dick up
for real
and I've done it that's how dumb I am it
didn't even bleed my dick you know I
didn't believe my dick was rock-hard no
it wasn't but I have [ __ ] tough skin
I'm like Luke Luke Cage my dick is like
the Luke Cage of dicks when I zipped my
onesie up might zip my dick up in my
onesie it just [ __ ] that's what Luke
Cage would do actually if he zipped up
his dick in his jeans he'd just go like
this dude my buddy Chappell who was
opening for me in Tempe Arizona he was
wearing a [ __ ] t-shirt with with
holes in it and and he was black and I
he's black and I didn't and he didn't
realize I was ideal why you [ __ ]
dress like Luke Cage and we laughed so
hard um David Wright at Pierce
underscore right what's her first name
change it is a piercer David I like how
his [ __ ] handle is way more British
than the [ __ ] regular one hi I'm
David right Oh Pierce Ryan Chris what
are your thoughts on gender reveal
parties just tell everybody what the
[ __ ] it is boy or girl you don't need to
have a cake I hear that the the bakers -
they're so stressed out because if they
get like a little bit of pink from the
inside on the outside or like of the box
if you open it up and there's pink in
the box somewhere you know on the inside
it's pink and you know it's gonna be a
girl you [ __ ] it up and it's not the
Baker's fault it's your fault for having
a [ __ ] gender-reveal party don't make
it so goddamn hard for the Baker to keep
the food dye inside the [ __ ] thing
okay
also just call everybody up hey it's a
boy send out a tweet it's a girl make an
email it's gonna be I don't know yet
they'll decide when they're older
because this country it needs to be very
very liberal but it'll have a dick and
balls yeah so
I mean not that one's crass you know so
yeah anyway that's it man we're over an
hour I think we're good we had a good we
had a fun show and also we've got a
merch I'm wearing one of these if you
see on the video this is the tire t
girl's shirt it fits and well as you can
see and it's and when you sweat in it it
looks nice too because I'm sweating my
[ __ ] balls off gently and then then
then mmm so yeah we got also
congratulations merchandise at the at
the store crystally accom congratulation
congratulation shirts we got you CUDA
shirts it's free conch shirts now you
don't have to get these shirts because
free conch but you can and you can rub
the podcast and spread the word of the
cult spread the good word of the cult
so that was episode 35 check out
movement watches and get 15% off today
with free shipping and free returns by
going to MVM t-dot-com / Congrats square
cash have you switched yet download the
free square cash app design your cash
card get it for iOS or Android now check
out the new video episodes that we're
doing and the clips on YouTube is very
cool they're very shareable I take out
some of the highlights of the week and
we just have those video clips so you
can see me talking about the [ __ ] and
video episodes go up on Thursdays if not
before
so here's the deal what you're not gonna
do is say hey we're the [ __ ] the
YouTube videos cuz the [ __ ] shits
gonna come out Tuesday's all right up
upcoming shows buy tickets on Chris
D'Elia calm Chris D'Elia calm Boone in
North Carolina Charlotte Australia which
the cities that we have Adelaide Perth
Melbourne Sydney Brisbane that's in
Australia we've got Columbus Ohio coming
up Irvine San Jose new date Winnipeg
that's gonna I think that's very close
to that's gonna go quick Winnipeg for
some reason they [ __ ] they come out
you got to watch man on fire if you
haven't watch it now tell your friends
to watch it that's the true word
cult rate and review and tweet me on
congrats pod or using hashtag hashtag
hashtag congratulations pot thank you
listen I'm not gonna keep doing this I
genuinely mean this - I'm not gonna keep
doing this [ __ ] podcast if the
numbers don't keep going up
so that's on you man if you're a true
baby or if you're a cult member spread
this word because I'm genuinely not
gonna keep doing it if the numbers don't
don't don't go up so you know men lie
women lie numbers don't lie in the great
[ __ ] philosopher Lil Wayne set I
think so anyway my babies thanks for
listening you guys do this [ __ ] and
remember dude that's how it is
congratulations
[Music]
you